il s'offre aux concours
ça va ça va ça va alors christophe la
presse vous a baptisé l'escroc des stars
de hollywood
mais on se rend compte en lisant votre
livre mais vit chez michel lafon que
c'est pas la meilleure définition et
surtout que c'est beaucoup mieux que ça
on pourrait dire vous êtes plutôt la
star les imposteurs nom wii a fait un
peu de mise
ouais alors ce livre raconte quatre
grandes périodes de votre vie votre
enfance en normandie
votre apprentissage de la vie parisienne
l'époque comme vous le dites votre
splendeur à paris puis à los angeles et
enfin la chute avant cinq ans de prison
au canada et aux états unis dès votre
sortie de prison
vous retournez sur les lieux de votre
enfance en normandie à pont-audemer
tout commence là un terrain derrière
l'église et le presbytère où le curé
tolère la caravane de vos parents vos
parents n'ont pas d'argent pour louer
une maison 8 mes parents sont beaux ma
mère est d'une beauté sensuelle
vénéneuse incandescent c'était une belle
femme
ouais c'est ma mère votre père costaud
revêt courageux bagarre un peu ouais
comme vous il le faut alors vous dites
mon père et ma mère d'un amour idolâtre
mais ma mère n'aime pas mon père elle
même qu'elle même oui
je pense qu'il ya des amours qui ils se
font pas ouais je pense que ma mère
était une belle femme et ça leur vrai
que sus avoir vis-à-vis de ça ses
vis-à-vis de mon père pour le respect de
mon père way s'est pas passé comme ça ça
marchait pas entre eux quoi non je crois
que mon père était un petit peu il
aimait pas une femme l'aimé des femmes
mais je crois que ma mère ne l'accepté
pas ouais voilà donc mais c'est toujours
triste vis-à-vis d'un enfant qui regarde
sa mère et santé on aime les deux est
tous déçus donc c'est difficile on peut
le comprendre mais c'est difficile point
pour un fils de voir ce que mon père est
devenu par rapport à moi ma mère donc je
le respect de mon père alors ils sont
rencontrés vos parents dans une fête
foraine
il y avait quelqu'un qui tentait de
violer votre mère votre père est arrivé
tel zorro il l'a sauvé ils ont couché
ensemble et vous naissez dit c'est un
accident bête c'est un accident mais je
sais pas si les bêtes
je crois que les choses se font dans la
vie il ya des gens qu'on est destiné je
sais pas si c'est de la bêtise mais bon
voilà c'est comme ça vous n'avez pas été
un enfant souhaité je crois pas ouais
c'est pas grave on est là ouais alors
votre père se bat souvent dans les bars
parce que ce sont toujours les mêmes
allusion qui le rendent furieux car sa
femme il faut le dire votre mère se
prostituent dans la caravane
je crois que ça énerve vrai tout le
monde moi le premier
ouais
voilà donc je pense que la colère ne mon
père a été justifiée ouais voilà alors
souvent votre mère vous dites sortir
dans la journée vous traîner dans le
village
vous avez rien à manger vous mettez à
fouiller les poubelles pouvoir bouffer
et vous avez cette phrase dans votre
bouquin qui est terrible vous dites il
ya toujours un imbécile de chiens pour
aboyer à la mort est une vieille pour
ricaner derrière ses rideaux
ah oui je pense qu'en fait les gens ils
ont peu de tolérance jour un semblant de
pitié en fait la vie a fait que doit
prendre sinon vous donne rien - on
comprend que les jugera comme une chose
rare alors un jour vous vous cachez et
vous regarder à travers la fenêtre de la
caravane et vous voyez votre mère sous
un homme elle est nue lui l'ailé les gr
8 elle a un sourire halluciné et les
jambes écartées
il vous dit que désormais vous serez
inapte à l'amour
je crois que lorsqu'on est jeune et
lorsqu'on est confronté à cette réalité
je crois que notre regard et de change
c'est hier qu'on devient plus enfants
ouais cette pureté en la terme
ce qui n'est une bousculent dans cette
démarche c'est comment une femme peut en
arriver un tel désarroi cas puisse ne
l'est plus avoir le respect de son fils
l'a fait ses choix
ouais et puis un jour votre mère s'en va
alors elle vous tourner carrément le dos
elle marche à pas pressés
elle monte dans une voiture vous vous
courrez vous accrocher à la la portière
et elle vous dit dégage
elle vous claque la porte sur le doigt
et elle vous sectionne l'auriculaire
gauche
vous l'avez jamais revu j'avais vu une
fois ma mère un jeu les revues pour
simplement pour leur gardien ensuite
j'ai pris une décision j'ai pris une
décision ne jamais lui reparler cette
décision gelée basée sur le fait pour
l'amour et le respect que j'avais une
mon père c'est un choix que j'ai fait
c'est un choix que j'assume et je
respecte ma mère par le fait qu'elle
m'ait donné la vie mais gésir pas que
une fois pas de quoi moi et ma mère on
peut parler en tant que fils ma mère
soit parce qu'on pourrait se dire mais
toujours en vie la wii elle vous
regardent peut-être peut-être rien à lui
dire là
jev voilà je la respecte
ouais tu fait que c'est ma mère alors
vous est envoyé chez votre grand mère
maternelle car la nouvelle femme de
votre père ne vous veut pas et le
compagnon de votre grand mère maternelle
c'est un gitan vois ça comment ça se
passait un peu mieux il vous apprend à
braconner et surtout il vous apprend à
rester de marbre quand les gendarmes
l'interrogé vous interroge et plus tard
ce sera utile avec les mecs du fbi aie
ça c'est pas moi j'aime pas l'uniforme
ouais mais bon ça c'est moi ouais on
peut le comprendre
on vend père c'était quelqu'un de bien
quelqu'un que j'aimais beaucoup il
paraît le romano on se comprenait pas
ouais mais j'étais un mec bien qu'avec
livre fut beaucoup de gens livre on voit
la g puis quand on est jeune voilà ils
sont deux matches c'est bien tu es bien
des gipsy ouais enfin et tout ce qui à
jour cette zone chaussures ils vont
chaparder une paire enfin je veux dire c
voilà bah oui mairie animé rivières et
de l'école 1
j'avais pas de chaussures dont qui ont
envoyé on a fait du chemin depuis
justement c'est là vous apprenez à
raconter des histoires vous démarrez
votre carrière de bonimenteur vous dites
comme votre grand-père et romano vous
dites que c'est un chef indien et que
vous vous êtes pieds nus parce que vous
êtes indiens aussi que vous faites ça
commence très jeune votre idée oui je
pense que lorsqu'on a une enfance quand
même comme la nôtre je suis pas le seul
y en a beaucoup je pense qu'en fait on
veut fuir c'est les enfants je vois j'ai
un fils qu'est-ce qu'ils font sont tous
devant imaginaire ouais ils jouent avec
leurs jouets
il rêve
lorsqu'il ya cette réalité en fait on
essaie d'en échapper
c'est assez intéressant de savoir
comment notre mémoire a peut être
sélectif dans mon cas j'aimais bien
rêver ouais y avait pas grand chose à
rêver à la maison donc on veut on rêvait
ailleurs voilà examen des restes
époque-là sympa d'être naïve très sympa
et alors c'est surtout l'époque où vous
découvrez la lecture et nietzsche et
vous en parler plus loin dans le livre
la mort faty c'est à dire l'amour du
destin c'est à dire aimer ce qui vous
arrive que ce soit bien ou mal
j'ai toujours aimé beaucoup nietzsche
pas ce que c'était c'est quelqu'un qui
était pas conclut intellectuellement il
ya beaucoup de corrompus intellectuelle
nietzsche il avait une vraie vérité une
vraie démarche il était tête compris les
petits étaient torturés je pense que
sans sa démarche il était vrai et ce qui
est vrai par l'existence et par la prod
des choses tout ce qui tue pas vous rend
plus fort ouais voilà on regarde un va
nu pieds puis en bas hollywood
je crois que c'est la détermination qui
fait les choses à 10 ans votre père vous
emmène dans un orphelinat et là bas vous
devenez vraiment le fils de personne
quoi parce que vous n'avez plus plus de
familles il est ivre est complètement à
vous même c'est très difficile à ce
moment là oui c'est difficile c'est que
je crois que il ya beaucoup de gens qui
passent par des difficultés dans
l'église dont j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de
mal à comprendre par rapport aux enfants
est quelque chose qui me dérange
énormément de ce soit les parents qui
abandonnent leurs enfants qui font cette
démarche est quelque chose de très très
malsain dans cette démarche
puisque c'est ta chère ouais c'est ce
que tu es ce que tu es c'est une partie
de toi même je n'arrive pas à comprendre
on peut trouver sans doute des
circonstances atténuantes vis-à-vis il a
vite ça mais c'est pas un justificatif
alors à 15 ans vous débarquez à paris
vous est recueillie par un homme d'une
vingtaine d'années qui s'appelle gilles
qui vous trouvent sur un banc dans une
station de métro c'est miraculeux est un
gosse de riche qui s'ennuient qui est
branché jet set qui vous emmène partout
mais pas de relation homosexuelle
je vais pas répondre à ça moi ça
m'arrive voir des gens qui sont pauvres
ils sont dans la rue je m'arrête et je
parle avec eux vous savez je crois qu'on
en est on
il ya quelque chose qui se passe dans
l'une ans aujourd'hui c'est personnes
s'arrêtent on pense qu'on est tous
quelque chose d'exceptionnel
quelque chose d'absolument on est juste
de passage
la réalité elle est là les gens veulent
pas la voir et la réalité elle est là on
est tous que ce soit les gens qui vous
voit publiquement on reste que des
humains on est fragile on et voilà donc
il faut s'arrêter
pourquoi il s'est arrêté sa démarche où
ils s'emmerder où il avait peut-être
pitié je ne sais pas j'ai eu l'occasion
de le remercier parce qu'il le regarde
je remercie voix la voix et les braves
nec
ouais dans tous les cas vous on est
vraiment partout vous avez connu le
palace est connu les grands restaurants
parisiens enfin la bonne vie et à 19 ans
qui s'offrent au concours vous commencez
vos premières combine alors par exemple
vous fait passer pour un élève de l'ena
saint-palais nan nan mais vous fait
passer pour un élève de l'ena qui veut
lancer un club chic dans le marais alors
il ya un mec qui vous prêtent 500 mille
francs aux blacks en liquide ah oui
évidemment un échec chez nous évidemment
la faire se fait pas et comme le mec
c'était de l'argent en salle il vous le
réclame pas bah voilà donc vous gardez
les cinq cent mille balles voila voila
commence fort achètent pas si c'était
forme
on commence et ce qui est génial c'est
que vous arrivez comme ça vous faire
passer pour un élève de l'ena le mec
s'aperçoit de rien
je sais pas peut-être les énarques sont
endormis ouais peut-être leurs neurones
ne fonctionne pas bien alors il ya quand
même quelque chose qui revient sans
arrêt dans votre livre c'est que vous
jouez sur la cupidité des gens dire que
les gens vous escroquer
c'est toujours des gens qui sont un prog
à quelqu'un qui est foncièrement honnête
pape allait prendre le large
voilà ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose aussi qui revient dans
votre bouquin c'est le train de vie
important c'est à dire que toujours vous
arrivez très bien sapés quand c'est los
angeles avec des hélicoptères des
blondes seront pas les blancs que c'est
bien non ouais si on n'est pas [ __ ]
c'est très bien toujours un train de vie
important à christophe on aime vivre
confortablement
à un moment c'est juste après vous
devenez christophe d'euros concours
sympathique
d'ailleurs on membres et du courrier au
nom de revoir je les remercie mon mines
christophe de rocquencourt pour
falsifier des titres de propriété
appartenant aux parents de votre petite
amie
oui j'ai vendu l'immeuble là vous
retrouver en taule quand même et vous
rencontrer l'assassin d'alain pacadis je
rencontrais une personne qui voit là
étaient impliqués dans cette histoire je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé dans la
suite donc à aider alain pacadis à
mourir on peut le dire il faut donner il
faut donner le bénéfice du doute dans
son histoire je la connais pas franchir
mais voilà mais vous l'aviez connu alain
pacadis joyau libération il serait
intelligent
oui traces de la nuit c'était un dandy
way après ce séjour en prison vous parti
aux usa à los angeles
alors là adresse de prestige voitures
haut de gamme vous devenez un pee pôle
incontournable
c'est extraordinaire comment un type
comme vous qui sort de pont-audemer
comment vous arrivez à devenir un pôle
incontournable à los angeles
je pense que il ya des choses qui sont
incontournables
lorsqu'on a une certaine aisance
financière lorsqu'on arrive avec des
divorces une forte toux ceux se remet
ensemble que ce soit hors showbiz c'est
la même cuisine
donc voilà l'argent appelle l'argent
vous fait passer pour le fils du
producteur dino de laurentiis sympa et
ça marche
ah ça marche et on avoue devenu ami avec
jean claude van damme mickey rourke que
michel polnareff vous dites je n'aurais
jamais pris un sou d'abord en parlant de
polnareff vous dites pour se faire
subtiliser 250 mille dollars
il faut les avoir café et puis vous
dites ils ont jamais porté plainte en
fait alors là vous rencontrer la fille
du président omar bongo et vous obtenez
un passeport américain
vous dites c'est le summum de mes rêves
le passeport américain pourquoi oui
c'était sympathique partant de normandie
avec les petites étoiles l'amérique
c'est pas mal alors vous continuez vos
arnaque mêlée tout se resserre encore un
coup fumant sous le nom de christophe
rockefeller
c'est extraordinaire c'est que personne
c'est incroyable en quad core et un chat
c'est fou ça en dit long quand même sur
la sur la bêtise humaine sûr que
personne réalise et met le descendant de
rockefeller à un anglais approximatif
les jeux c'est à dire que c'est même
plus de la bêtise ouais genre un
problème de neurones ouais
c'est plus de la bêtise c'est fou la
bêtise on peut se tromper
ouais là c'est de la connerie humaine
c'est les gens que vous êtes christophe
rauck févr oui non non mais bon c'est
pathétique
ouais ouais ce qu'on peut dire de plus
c'est pathétique
ce qui est encore plus pathétique c'est
qu'ils font des affaires
ouais de mauvaises mains tellement
rencontre ouais alors vous vous
retrouvez en prison d'abord au canada
puis aux usa et vous raconter dans ce
livre donc mais vie vous raconter la
prison américaine
le choc par exemple le chemin c'est une
arme une arme bricoler avec n'importe
quoi en fait c'est l'armé blanche quoi
vous pouvez vous pouvez prendre un stylo
des manières voilà vous pouvez prendre
une boîte de thon vous aurez une boîte
de thon le cern où le prix on les 10
voulait on était du sauvage la machine à
cirage la machine elle retourne voilà
elle retourne d'affaires et alors vous
parlez de la haine raciale et de la
guerre des gangs dans ces prisons
américaines vous dites on peut tuer pour
un oui pour un non par exemple un jour
il ya un mec qui touche à un
plateau-repas de quelqu'un d'autre
six morts le système carcéral américain
et beaucoup différent de notre système
en europe un système très violent le
milieu carcéral en france c'est le
milieu carcéral américain cccc de mon
bras était c'est incomparable aux états
unis la vie n'a pas vraiment beaucoup de
prix c'est effarant par exemple à new
york
je crois que c'était en 2002 2003 il y
avait des jeunes qui venaient pour les
baskets des nike
il y avait toute une môme de nike était
sortie et il y avait des jeunes qui
mettait des cagoules et passait dans la
rue par la 5e avenue et prenez basket
j'ai pas c'est quand même effarant
si vous voulez basket où mes chaussures
scrutin ouais il avant de flinguer le
mec paumé lui demander sa pointure au
moins quelqu'un ça serait préférable
mais si vous avez le temps c'est ça le
problème
mais elle va voir le temps alors le
producteur thomas langmann qui est le
parrain de votre fils est venu vous voir
en prison au canada
oui il va faire un film à partir de
votre vie tout à fait vous avez joué le
rôle
non je pense pas pourquoi non je crois
qu'il faut laisser ça aux personnes qui
sont qui sont doués pour faire alors
maintenant vous étrangers rangée où ils
tranquille vous avez payez votre dette à
la société vous adonner 1,2 million de
dollars à la justice américaine c'est un
bon citoyen maintenant un bon citoyen
france calle vos impôts 33%
ben voilà vous êtes des regrets il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui disent oui je
regrette la démarche allait pas là pour
moi je pense que lorsqu'on la société
vous condamnent vous avez commis un
délit vous pliez 50 votre existence 4
mètres sur 4 m qu'est ce que vous voulez
je vous dise de plus alors donc il faut
que je fasse 5 ans de prison que je paye
ma dette et que je voulais à pourvoir
qu'est ce que voulez vous que je vous
dise
excusez moi je peux plus m'excuser j'ai
payé 5 ans je vous dois rien donc coin
ou d'y donner tous ces imposteurs parce
qu'on essaye tous des chapelles réalité
d'une manière ou d'une autre
bien sûr la réalité elle n'est pas très
belle non moi je passais tout à l'heure
et je regardais sur un trottoir je
voyais quelqu'un qui avait une tente
votre toit ouais on va mal
ouais on va vraiment mal on s'arrête
même pu on regarde on dira oui c'est
triste
on a un petit regard de compassion mais
en fait la bière continue donc ses il ya
quand même quelque chose de vraiment
très malsain dans cette démarche
alors vous en faites vous avez voulu
échapper à votre vie on l'a vu la vie
avec cette mère qui se prostituent dans
la caravane c'est pour cela sans doute
que vous avez essayé de vivre toutes ces
autres existence maintenant que vous
l'avez raconté dans ce livre quand vous
avez avoué
est-ce que avoué c'est fini quoi
maintenant de vous sentir et ce à quoi
c'est pas le fait d'être libéré et je
crois qu'il ya un moment de son
existence
on fait ce qu'on doit faire puis ensuite
on tourne la page
et si on tourne une page en quoi on fait
on la trouvera un vêtement il faut
passer à autre chose
vous êtes réconcilier que vos fantôme
maintenant je leur parle
lorsque vous avez été arrêté à vancouver
vous aviez 4 bible dans un sac louis
vuitton vous dit la foi a toujours
dominé ma vie bien sûr quand vous étiez
en prison vous priez beaucoup et je
pense pas que c'est le fait d'être en
prison je pense qu'on il faut rester
humble je pense que penser qu'on ait
lieu la supériorité dans l'humanité
c'est de la vanité
à mon sens il est bien évident qu'il ya
quelque chose de supérieur
donc on l'appelle dieu voilà il a et ya
eu beaucoup de compassion à mon égard je
l'en remercie
on va voir à nos comptes plus tard
christophe on va faire une interview
attrape moi si tu peux
quelle a été identique et que vous avez
préféré prendre à calais quelle identité
avez-vous gardé le plus longtemps
3 populaire qu'est l'identité était la
plus difficile à porter 3faire quelle
identité était vraiment une mauvaise
idée
rock quelle identité vous ressembler le
plus coté va être surpris or en cours
quel est votre plus beau coup celui là
qu'est ce qui vous avait plus rapporté
les affaires qu'est ce qui vous a le
plus amusé la connerie humaine
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus dur 50
prison à quel moment vous êtes dit je
vais trop loin quand l'avez vu à aimar
est qu'est-ce qui vous motive et le plus
parti de rien d'arriver
qu'est ce qui a failli vous griller le
plus souvent moi même à quoi était vous
particulièrement bon connaître la nature
humaine qui avez vous toujours refusé
d'arnaquer les personnes qui ont rien à
qui n'avez vous jamais pu piquer de la
thune ce qu avait pas de vanité
combien avez vous mis de côté un peu
combien 1 et des 0 combien avez vous dû
rendre un million de dollars ah oui le
billet vert quelle fut votre plus grosse
erreur rendre l'argent
je c'est vrai j'avais pas pensé tu auras
un million de 2 va lui même on va
repartir on va aller les voir alors
demandé qu'il nous fasse un reçu qu'est
ce qui vous a trahis et l'amitié ça vous
combien les droits de votre histoire
pour le cinéma un million d'euros vous
voyez qui pour jouer votre rôle au
cinéma
samy naceri
braun akers ça c'est pas bête très bonne
à que je pense qu'il a il a des
convictions faut lui laisser
vincent cassel je le rencontre et ouais
j'ai pas regardé ses courbes américain
johnny depp
non c'est un mec bien et maintenant
c'est fini les conneries
j'arrête les conneries si ça a été des
conneries ça passe je pense pas que ça a
été des conneries c'était une démarche
elle était peut-être pas bonne un choix
pas de calais lens à lille pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de ligne lundi tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou